AnAnnie et Luc, bonsoir.
L'L'état des routes, est-ce que
c'c'est parce qu'on n'a pas mis
asassez d'argent?
- - On en a pas mis assez et on
n'n'en mettra pas plus. Que ce
sosoit unique pour l'autre. Pour
fafaire des travaux en profonde,
égégouts, assez aqueducs, dalles
dede béton, asphalte, il faut
ououvrir la rue et c'est long et
c'c'est cher. Si on veut juste
fafaire du resurfaçage, on peutn
fafaire plus mais ça dure combin
dede temps?
- - Êtes-vous aussi pessimiste
AnAnnie?
- - Non pas du tout. Prioriser,
c'c'est renoncé à aututre chosÇa
dédépend de la priorité de
l'l'administration. Si la prioré
TITIRU, l'arrondissement choisit
seses priorités. Ils ont un budt
etet on se dit on en met 25 % ds
lala chaussée cette année, 10 %
dadans les parties.
OnOn est capable de varier maisl
fafaut avoir un plplan. Pas juse
susur un an mais sur 10 ans avec
leles rues vertes, les jaunes et
leles rouges. À chaque anannée,n
enen choisit dans les districts.
- - Je vais vous donner un
exexemple. Le budget du plateau
vavais vous donner un exemple. e
bubudget du plateau Mont-Royal,i
onon mettait dans le resurfaçag,
d'd'en vénérer Parc Extension, e
teterritoire est tellement grand
quque la proportion des travaux
ququ'on peut faire sur une année
papar rapport au nombre de
kikilomètrtres de rues et encore
plplus petite. Ça nous faisait
pepermettre de faire 1,10 km par
anannée. C'est risibel.
LeLe problèmeme est généré par e
popoids des camions. Les propres
vévéhicules de la ville, la
nonouvelle souffleuse avec de
grgrosses têtetes, les camions e
trtransport de neige et les
auautobus articulés sont tous ls
trtrois en haut de la capacité e
poportance de la rue. Après s çl
y y a tous les autres vévéhicule
lilivraison qui sont de plus en
plplus gros.
- - Ça revient à c ce qu'on dist
lala semaine dernière, , les
cacamions.
- - Il y a quand même u une log.
LeLes camions de déneigement avc
leles souffleuse, on ne sortira
papas nos Parti libéral. Il va
fafalloir qu'on les enlèveve pae
quque les gens vont chialer si n
nene ramasse pas la neige
rarapidement.
IlIl faut pouvoir jauger entre s
dedeux.
- - Quand on ouvre une rue pour
leles conduites en plan et qu'on
leles change, ce serait peut-ête
bibien de faire le resurfaçage e
lala rue aussi en mêmeme temps.
- - Oui, mais ça dépend si on la
chchange dans le sens de la
lolongueur de la rue. À ce mome-
llà l le refaire le resurfaçage
efeffet.
- - Je vous le confirme, il n'et
papas fait. Les revenus de Valée
PlPlante, c'est réglé. Un salaie
dede mairesse et de revenus de
loloyer. Denis Coderre dit :
atattendez, je vais vous donner
totous mes clients mais je ne px
papas vous donner tous les détas
dede mes contrats privés. Qu'en
pepensez-vous?
- - C'est pas acceptable.
OnOn veut savoir s'il a parlé de
BeBellevalle, s'il a parlé de la
tataille des immeubles, s'il a
paparlé avec evenko.
IlIl a travaillé pour Stingrai.
BoBoiko est à l la têtete de Sti
ququi supporte les Bellevalle.
- - Je suis partagé parce que
MoMonsieur Coderre en 2013
lolorsqu'il s'est présenté comme
cicitoyen, il avait commencé cee
trtradition de dire : on va
dédéposer nos états financiers.l
avavait été parce qu'il avait ds
cacandidats qui venaient un peu
papartout. La raison pour laquee
ilil l'avait fait, c'était de de
ilil faut que les citoyens aient
unune confiance, il faut que ce
sosoit transparent. Ce que je
m'm'explique mal, c'est
ququ'aujourd'hui, si on veut
enencore avoir la confiance et a
trtransparence, il faut qu'il
pupuisse le faire. La loi ne
l'l'oblige pas, soyons clairs,
mamais cependant la tradition ns
didit qu'il faut déposer les
rarapports d'impôt. P Pour ce qi
esest de la liste de ses client,
ilil attendra qu'il dépose son
rarapport d'impôt.t. Plus il en
paparle, moins il agit, plus ile
fafait du totort.
- - Mais vous seriez d'accord pr
ququ'il ne donne pas les détails
dede tous ces contrats.
- - Qu'il dépose son rapport
d'd'impôt.t. Qu'il arrêtete de r
llà-d-dessus parce qu'il fait je
s's'enfoncer.
- - Il est dit qu'il a été payée
dodouble du salaire du maire qui
esest autour de 200 000 $. Envin
40400 000 $. On ne l'a pas payé
40400 000 $ possédant des
rérédactions. Il y a une raison
popour laquelle on l'a payé. Es-
cece que ça aurait un rapport ac
lala vie municipale?
- - Les gens vont suivre la COP
2626.
OnOn a commencé les l'émissions
avavec ça.
AuAu niveau des villes, est-ce
ququ'il y a des leviers. Quels
sosont les leviers qui peuvent
chchanger pour un maire ou une
mamairesse?
- - Il faut planter des arbres
prprocoches de la pollution. Les
ararbrbres qui sont prêtsts dess
dodominants et qui absorbent la
popollution de la rue absorbe
bebeaucoup de pollution. Au milu
dede la forêt t il n'en absorbe
plplus. Il faut planter en ville
ouoù il y a beaucoup de trafic.
- - Aux abords de la
mémétropolitaine. À l'époque onn
avavait planté. Ça a pris du tes
paparce que c'est un milieu
didifficile. Les arbres ont
susurvécu et ça fonctionne.
LoLocalement dans chacun des
ararrondissements il y a des îls
dede chaleur. Commençons par.
ObObligé de changer la planètete
jojour au lendemain. Les îlotste
chchaleur, planter des arbres sr
leles trottoirs où il n'y en a
papas, essayez de verdir un peu
dadans les rues lorsqu'on ne pet
papas mettre d'arbres. Je pense
quque les arrondissements doivet
lele faire à p plus petite éche.
- - Un sujet qui va vous faire
réréagir j'en suis certain, les
didiscours de Michael Rousseau,
PDPDG d'Air Canada qui vit à
MoMontréal mercredi devant la
chchambre de commerce du grand
MoMontréal. On annonce déjà q ql
nene prononcera pas un mot de
frfrançais. On le confirme
auaujourd'hui par son bureau.
AiAir Canada, son siège s sociar
lala loi et à Monontréal. Commet
vovous réagissez?
- - Je ne comprends pas que la
chchambre de commerce maintienne
soson invitation.
QuQue toutes les interventions e
lala chambre de commerce visentà
didire que Montréal est une vile
ququi a un visage francophone, e
ququi la rend distincte du reste
dede l'Amérique. On fait une
pupublicité monstrue pour attirr
dedes investisseurs. Quand vient
lele temps de mettre ses bottest
dede dire à queuelqu'un : tu nex
papas venir ici parler juste en
ananglais, ils ne le font pas.
- - Les babines ne suivent pas s
bobottines. C'est quand mêmeme e
sisiègege social est sis à M Mo.
MoMontréal est la premièrere vie
frfrancophone en Amérique du No.
OnOn n'arrête p pas de s'en van.
OnOn parle de défendre le françs
etet le président d'Air Canada i
s's'appelle Rousseau, écrit en
frfrançais, qui n'est pas capabe
dede venir nous faire un discous
enen français, qui aurait pu ête
bibililingue, il aurait pu parln
pepeu u en français à touout le.
IlIl reste à Monontréal depuis .
- - Tout en français, ça aurait
étété impossible. Mais qu'il n'a
auaucun mot de françnçais, j'avs
susursauté beaucoup de gens.
- - Et qu'on accepte ça ici para
chchambre de commerce, je suis
dédéçu.
- - Les gens d'affaires sont aui
dedevenus des francophones c'es-
àà-d-dire que 80 % des gens
d'd'affaires à M Montréal sont
frfrancophones.
DoDonc c'est pas comme si il
didisait j'ai pas par la
popopulation, je parle juste aux
gegens d'affaires. Les gens
d'd'affaires aussi de vous
enentendre en français.
- - En terminant, avant de vous
lalaisser aller, combien il y au
dede votre participation... 12,.
OnOn n'a pas de comparable parce
quque il n'y avait pas deux jous
avavant, mais il me sembmble que
c'c'est pas pire.
- - C'est sur deux jours. On le
sesera demain parce que les
trtroupes sont en train de valir
ququi est allé voter. Ils ont ru
lala liste. D'ici demain on sera
ququel type d'électeur est sorti
popour aller voter et on va
popouvoir savoir de quelle parte
esest en avance.
MaMais effectivement c'est sur
dedeux jours donc c'est difficie
dede dire... c'était 6 % la dere
fofois.
C'C'est un peu difficile
auaujourd'hui de pouvoir dire
ququ'il y en a un qui est en
avavance ou pas.
- - Mais si le passé est garanti
prprésent, Denis Coderre a
totoujours été fort sur le vote
papar anticipation. Projet
MoMontréal a toujours perdu le
vovotre participation.
- - Quand vos proches vous
dedemandent : toi tu connais ça,
ququi va gagner? Vous dites quo?
- - 5 % davantage pour Valérie
PlPlante.
- - Vous êtes s plus solide
auaujourd'hui.
- - J'avais rabaissé un petit pu
momon coup mais là j je le ress.
AÀ cause du vote de Hollness qui
esest présentement à 12 2 % dans
sosondages.
- - Moi c'est la semaine des los
cocouteaux. C'est la dernièrere
sesemaine de la campagne, c'està
quque tout sort. Une petite roc,
unun sourire croche, ça peut
babalancer d'un côtété comme de
l'l'autre. Cependant ceux qui st
dédéjà s sûrs, , on ne les chana
papas. Ce sont les indices de
ququ'on doit convaincre. Avec M.
CoCoderre et Madame Valérie
PlPlante, il faudra que les deux
sosoient séduisants.
- - On va parler plus tard d